[Musique]
la sécurité doit être une priorité
absolue pour l'avenir de l'europe et
pour l'avenir de nos enfants
j'attends de l'europe qu'elle qu'elle
lutte contre la menace islamiste qu'elle
protège nos frontières les républicains
font de la sécurité un enjeu majeur de
leur programme
c'est pour ça que le 26 mai prochain aux
élections européennes je voterai pour
les républicains
pour moi la culture européenne devraient
être réaffirmés et faire partie du
programme des républicains la pac
aujourd'hui à représente une grosse
partie du revenu des agriculteurs
on a besoin d'une pac forte pour la
modernisation de nos exploitations
l'objectif c'est le soutien de nos pme
la préservation des savoir-faire rare
des savoir faire d'excellence pour
l'europe et pour la france
je voterai le 26 mai prochain dans le
cadre des élections européennes pour les
républicains
je pense vraiment qu'il faudrait inciter
tous les jeunes à partir en erasmus pour
découvrir la civilisation européenne et
c'est pour ça que je voterai pour eux le
26 mai prochain
les républicains des propositions
concrètes et c'est pour ça que le 26 mai
j'irai voter pour les républicains
aujourd'hui nous avons un besoin énorme
de reconquérir des parts de marché car
le marché intérieur et n'est plus
suffisant pour les transporteurs
français
nous avons besoin de cette harmonisation
au niveau européen pour défendre le
transport et pour l'avenir du transport
routier français
l'intelligence artificielle et au
numérique font partie intégrante de nos
vies
la france et l'union européenne doivent
investir et soutenir massivement nos
entreprises et nos startups pour ne pas
qu'on se laisse dominer par une
concurrence d'autant plus omniprésente
de plus en plus féroce de la part de la
chine et des usa les républicains ont
des réponses concrètes pour l'europe de
demain
c'est pour cela que je voterai heller le
26 mai prochain aux élections
européennes
[Musique]